so not too long ago at San Diego
comic-con we were showed some clips of
Avengers infinity war that we haven't
seen in any of the trailers yet as we
impatiently await those new trailers
that's going to come out right before
the movie Entertainment Weekly's did us
a favor and they've actually given us
some photos that are snapshots of some
of the scenes that we saw at San Diego
comic-con the first one is the one
that's really really big right now
circling around the web because it's
just so awesome it's fan OHS literally
grabbing a moon out of orbit and
throwing it at the Avengers it appears
that he only has two stones in the
Infinity Gauntlet right now the space
stone and a Power Stone Loki gives
Stannis of space stone we know that and
it's most likely that Fano stole the
power stone from Xander which is where
it was kept aw did us another favor by
confirming that this is actually Thanos
his homeworld Titan for a while
everybody thought it was gonna be ons
and art but thanks DW for clearing that
up for us this is only two Infinity
stones out of the six imagine what Danis
can do was six because with only two he
literally grabs the moon out of orbit
and throws it at the adventures and most
likely destroys a planet
the next photo we have is of Tony Stark
aka Iron Man Doctor Strange dr. banner
and Wong and this is kind of cool
because it shows some of the teams that
the Avengers will split up in in
Avengers infinity war because there's
just so many characters in it it's gonna
be awesome so the next image it shows
Captain America war machine and Black
Widow
as we can see war machine he's walking
again with some tech help from Tony
Stark of course the really interesting
thing about this photo is it looks like
they're taking some of the storyline
from Secret Avengers and I'm excited to
see how they're gonna tie the story into
the movie and this one we have Sheree
who is the chief of technology for what
Conda and again Wakanda is the most
technologically advanced country in the
MCU we can see here that she's
collaborating with banner who himself is
a genius so I have no doubt that they're
coming up with some crazy awesome
weapons to use to fight against Thanos
here we have spider-man on his way to
confront Thanos in the current trailers
that are out we see spider-man on a bus
his spidey senses tingle he looks out
the window and sees an alien spaceship
this is a photo of him going to that
spaceship this next photo that we have
really excites me we have Thor rocket
and teen group they are most likely
going to make Thor's new hammer storm
breaker on the planet of neduvaali which
is where his first hammer was made I'm
excited to see this team on screen
because I think Thor rocket and teen
Groot are gonna make for some awesome
action scenes and some hilarious comedy
as well here we have Loki and judging by
the background and the look on his face
he is in the presence of Thanos which
leads me to believe that this is where
he gives Thanos the space stone the last
photo that we have is a black panther in
Wakanda Black Panther is at the front of
his army ready for battle and if you
look to the right a row back you can see
Captain America and Bucky who is now
known as the white wolf
there have been rumors in theories that
the soul stone is in Wakanda so Thanos
will have to come retrieve it this is
most likely a clip of Black Panther what
Condon's and some of the Avengers making
a final stand against Thanos and his
attempt to get the soul stone so those
are all the photos that Entertainment
Weekly came out with I hope they make
you as excited as I am about Avengers
infinity war coming out just next month
and hopefully we'll get a new trailer
soon so that's it for my update video if
you liked it please be sure to give it a
thumbs up and please subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date on Avengers
infinity war Marvel and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
and have a great day